you're trying to relate to someone
you're not dealing the for aspect of it
okay so here we have very similar things
you have to not do a form so a lot of
you went to Y manucci like we weren't
doing Y manucci and now and so now
you're doing a Toshi Zuki and you just
have the way you would do it for y got
it
or um so know this one is here boom boom
look do you see so here if he goes and
he makes contact oh that's the rotating
cross you see keep it there please you
do an embrionic and this goes this way
okay boom it's not going to be here
okay
boom
embryonic
rotate boom
boom rotate boom but we're going to use
the application time is for both of
because it makes that a little less
awkward but that's still the defensive
offens offensive pack of
[Music]
option so do you guys see how I'm in
that
[Music]
he's still doing the same Kitty and
showman and I'm still doing thei and
still still a stop
hit
boom
[Music]
boom all right let's try okay so we just
G given something else for the sword to
be I
with and just sticking to it it's very
effortless if I
harmonize begin to the
Y
for
you get some going so I don't ENT
there
here go back put it in my
face you see then you do it then I have
to wait till it goes
over switch
do you see go over here like
that so I'm doing that the whole watch
boom
look enter enter again okay boom boom
comes
in don't
deviate just wait and you'll feel the Y
opening right there is the
guard
here we go all
right okay so right
here why why don't I
just run in you see and cut off his
hand because he's going to stick his Joe
on the center line okay so watch it it's
it's what's happening in between the the
atoshi movements that keep me at Bay
okay so we go again so boom hop when
what he's going to do is he knows he has
to get out of the way of that thing you
get it but he's going to as he goes to
match my Center he's going to put this
here go foot maneuver foot maneuver it's
going to go there there first before it
goes here got it so it show
you okay so I going one you see it's
right there and if I just follow the yin
of his sword it'll go there I go like
this no I lost the I adhesion so you got
to go really slow so this goes
around he goes it fell off
it's right
there so I don't go like
this you pay attention I I my weapon is
going to be outside and you're just
going to run at
me this weapon goes boom here into the
okay that's why I don't keep running
forward it would beho me to run forward
and jam up his longer weapon
so we got to go slower it's going to be
here to you boom stop me yeah okay I
still take what I
can this is embryonic timing just fine
absorb it's going to come around again
okay now if you
do uh a Toshi sui like in the 36 Joe so
you're going to come up get off the line
you see like
that you see that let's do that again
where we
were same problem's going to happen he
goes up then I'm going to just come
in you get
it cuz that's the yin opening so in the
same way there it is right there boom
it's right here come in you can't come
in do you see then the weapon
comes I deal with the weapon then the
I'll do it
incorrectly one here you see
that here you see that I didn't occupy
and stop the
penetration slower
correctly boom boom boom there it is
Boom
now you force him to stay
there and then it brings sense to the
other
stuff slow down for you boom he keeps
connection he rotates the
cross and he goes
underneath
boom one boom boom here
boom
Okay add those components here we go